foreign
enough time with this location title to
realize that flipping its spells mocks
out also I know we're not expecting 100
True adaptation of the secret Invasion
run but renaming Russia to present day
is an interesting creative Liberty
contributing to the growing E-Waste
Problem by throwing your burner phone on
the ground instead of burning it that's
what you're supposed to do right moving
your gun from your sock to your pants so
as the audience we know you have a gun
in that we might get to see you shoot
yourself in the ass imagine world
without narration every day operation
treadstone are we sitting the wrong show
or is Disney secretly purchased
Universal so they can make a crossover
with the Bourne Universe yes that's a
joke but why does it feel like it might
not be episode goes with the standard
spy mood board cliche also Terror in
Munich mass shooting motive unnecessary
post-excite note mint that's precisely
what they want you to think trying to
convince someone that you aren't a
conspiracy nut by using the go to slogan
every conspiracy nut is used since
November 22nd 1963 or is that what
Marvel wants us to think so you think
the same people are behind all of this
not people Scrolls hey Scrolls can be
people too isn't that the point Scrolls
could be anybody anywhere at any time so
in theory this would be a society where
as a person you could present any way in
which you would like with no fear of
persecution and no one giving are we
sure we don't want the Scrolls in charge
I need to give them something more than
just theories I need evidence and the
super secret location of the evidence is
behind this desk also Barrick done with
your Darion does indeed have some very
compelling evidence but you'd be
forgiven for thinking he's a conspiracy
seeking lunatic considering he opened
with the wild conspiracy instead of the
hard evidence
choking your bilbo Ross rolls down the
stairs and into one of the most
incomprehensible action shots I've ever
seen episode will now showcase the
motion activated Lighting in the
stairwell for all of the overly
Dramatics sometime
[Music]
Talos trusting that the shapeshifter is
shifted shape into the shape shifter you
know is the known to be trustworthy
shapeshifter here's one of you what do
you mean one of you also now Begins the
inevitable no one is who you think they
are but maybe they are but maybe who the
knows hook of the show meaning I'll
have to devote 75 of my brain power to
guessing suspecting and generally
pondering who is or isn't a scroll
instead of Simply enjoying the show yes
I could utilize the other 25 for show
enjoyment but you see it's already been
partitioned for puns and Archer
references he's one of them what do you
mean one of them apparently these
opening credits were designed by an AI
program instead of a human so should we
send it for robbing an artist of
meaningful work in a world where they're
already underpaid and underappreciated
or do we remove a sin for being on brand
for the theme of the series and
embracing the inevitability of new
technologies or do we look a distraction
people who think the whole please remain
in your seats until the seat belt sign
has been turned off thing doesn't apply
to them also it's one thing to be up in
the ass of AI it's another thing to be
up in the ass of Spielberg's AI
artificial intelligence I got kicked off
the council pushed into Exile Taylor's
is bringing Nick up to speed on some
pretty radical developments about the
Scrolls on Earth and as nice as this
Exposition is for us why does a fury
already know this he hasn't been in a
cave with a box of scraps he's been
working on an orbital weapon system I
could have updated him at any point but
decided to wait until they had exactly
all time to save the day ravik is
now the newest member of the scroll
Council I present to you the newest
product from sinsang the hollow's
position bad where is it oddly timed
biology lessons scrolls are immune to
radioactivity of course they are Russia
has the most abandoned nuclear plants on
Earth of course they do these plants
they're not on the books of course they
aren't also if that's true what was the
point of all these little radioactive
graphics on your map just for funsies
looks like in this round we have James
Rhodes and Dermot Mulroney but
unfortunately there's only enough time
for them to be baffled by the idea that
Nick Fury might have had some chores to
do so tune in next week to maybe or
maybe not find out on who is the scroll
isn't Fury is building out the most
complex Aerospace defense system in the
history of mankind you can't just leave
right I mean that's super weird isn't it
you'd think there'd be steps in place to
make sure Nick do what I want Fury
couldn't leave the station without prior
approval or without setting off all the
alarms you sure would think that
wouldn't you Mr President let's see
large black man Moscow playing Guess Who
with the British Fury planning a bug is
so not surprising that we'll wonder why
they didn't search him more thoroughly
and why they don't immediately sweep the
room after he's gone I think Thanos is
snapping against you taught you that no
matter how hard you fight for what's
right there's always someone stronger to
undermine you what the is this is
she trying to incept him sure this guy
was suddenly turned to dust and then
resurrected five years later but people
changed for a lot of reasons and they
don't need you speculating on the nature
of their trauma I let your man take me
so I could get to you title of my sex
tape in case you confused it with 310
made up units of measurement southwest
of Moscow take your natural form uh make
sure you do so behind your hat as
She-Hulk rightfully pointed out this
transformation ain't cheap we're not
looking to overwork the AI Workforce
into a rebellion yet welcome to New
skrillos you've arrived just in time to
be my expositional walk and talk guinea
pigs so we can tell the audience what a
scrollos is also assuming that an alien
species would show the same lack of
creativity as the Europeans who took
monahata and named it New Amsterdam and
the Europeans who took New Amsterdam and
named it New York and the Europeans who
took New York and named it new orange
and you get the point first furthermore
also Lee how did she know someone was
coming the guard certainly didn't have
time to message her did she just happen
to be driving past the entrance I mean
that seems super weird because there's
all down here other than Exposition
here have this unwrapped produce that I
keep in the glove compartment also why
are we speaking English right now
instead of a scroll language we grow
only squirrel produce here drink scroll
wine West roasting okay now you're just
naming things and putting scroll in
front of it also you wear Scrolls skins
I mean I guess I do wear human skins but
I don't like this phrasing I suppose
this is scroll soccer that's right I
called it soccer America the Warriors
keep our human food the longer we attach
to our shells the less likely we can be
identified by humans and Scrolls alike
plus the show's been a ton of money
getting Emilia Clarke to play me and
it'd be a shame if we hit her in
prosthetics for the whole season what's
behind there
Victory the boat what the hell do the
squirrels want with the oldest serving
Naval vessel in the world commissioned
in 1758 complete with 104 guns don't get
me wrong I'd love to see some pirate
Scrolls but how the hell did they get it
from Portsmouth England all the way to
oh she's being metaphorically ambiguous
isn't she fine but that's much less fun
than my thing okay these are my six
should have found this for no
other reason than it's visibly changing
colors I'm considered good looking
amongst my kindly you know I know a
bunch of good looking squirrels knew
anyone okay I'm glad these two besties
are picking up where they left off but
I'm not glad the story that wants me to
think the scroll terrorist threat is
urgent is also making time for this she
will annihilate any and everyone who's
ever even heard the name ravik being the
living proof that what you just said was
over exaggerated BS you
come with me we don't even see him look
in a Direction let alone her Direction
yet Gaia correctly guesses which you he
was talking to
tension between these two or does this
guy just not like it when people slam
car doors a lot of what is going on here
could have been cleared up if they just
gave this guy a scroll Apple Nicholas
Joseph Fury you're conducting an
unauthorized operation on foreign soil
why are you not concealing your weapon
in public
[Music]
in Captain America the Winter Soldier
did we not see this man tunnel his way
out of a flipped car through sheet metal
asphalt concrete and whatever else is
beneath the roadway all in a few seconds
but he's flummoxed by a chained door not
bad for 136 year old wow yeah not even
40 in human years haven't even gone on
my mid-life crisis shopping spree yet
what you get for yours The Avengers let
us see fun banter took precedence over
quietly infiltrating the shop of a bomb
Builder got eyes on an impossible Person
of Interest no you don't there's
like a second and a half window of time
where it was possible for you to have
caught sight of Familia here and you
just so happen to be looking the right
way not to mention the nonsense that you
were able to recognize her at the
distance but there belong to Louis XV
it's Priceless everything is priceless
silly gets blown to bits and a hail of
bullets no everything is not Priceless
the Italian combo from the deli down the
street is 8.99 before the bullets we're
gonna go ahead and call that a lie
everybody gets one nobody gets two we're
kind of saying is that nobody gets to
lie twice nobody how is there anyone
left in the MCU what about the heroes
that have to lie about their identity
what about Talos the man you're working
with that is standing in this room and
has to lie every day I will never ever
ever forgive hyperbolic threats well I
guess it isn't a Marvel property unless
I've had at least one bout of nausea
induced by 17 trillion cuts a second
imagine getting an AI to create your
opening credits but not taking the time
to also ask them how do I make my action
scenes less vomity
I said no this will work well in the
service of building tension between
these two but you could have shot him in
the kneecaps Nick he still has the
information you need
where did you come from or at least how
in the TV time work did you get here so
fast this is not what you mother would
have wanted damn it I thought guy got
into this position on her Merit but
turns out she's an EPO baby her last
words fine Gaia she's dead man she
didn't know her mother was dead either I
guess I'm connecting with these
characters through their pain but I
vaguely remember sitting down to watch a
suspense thriller not a family drama you
can't protect anyone
he's letting her go okay that's his
daughter but she has a bomb I know that
World War III eventually leads to the
Vulcans arriving the formation of
Starfleet and utopian future but damn it
you shouldn't know that
[Music]
Fury orders a pint here but when we see
them at the table he's drinking a bottle
which is absolutely not a pint and the
MCU Golden Days really are behind us
aren't they are you gonna tell me why
you abandoned earth oh building out
saber casual bar chats about the most
complex Aerospace defense system in the
history of mankind let's just say I had
a crisis of Faith so why'd you come back
there's being cool under pressure and
then there's drinking and playing chess
in a bar while you know that your enemy
has radioactive bombs they intend to use
you're not ready for this Fury can we
please just pretend he's ready the
semi-retired hero being forced back to
fight the good fight Trope is getting so
tired that it ironically should itself
be retired until we're prepared to drag
it back into action with a more original
conceit so check your footing otherwise
someone's gonna get hurt she said
ominously as if having some kind of
foreknowledge about the episode's climax
they arrived at the same car did they
have to get out to have this chat The
Invasion may be secret but all these
characters seem set on ensuring that
nothing else is a lot of backpacks in
Central Moscow guys painted ours with
infrared spray you're only telling them
this now what if they hadn't brought the
fancy glasses that we're seeing for the
first time ever we missed house and
you're surprised you have three people
covering this huge ass square at nothing
more than ground level of course you
missed it aren't they supposed
to be the best spies in the U.S our
reward for Patiently letting this
episode go through the motions of
setting up the story is that we now get
to watch these three badly chase a
MacGuffin through a crowded square at
the pace of a quick walk
Scrolls I mean kids also this seems to
be the same little girl Fury saw earlier
so does Graphics been some of his off
hours hanging out as a six-year-old with
a Russian family
graphic clearly doesn't care about Fury
knowing that he's shape-shifting but
what about all the people on the other
side of this stand that would clearly
see this tiny girl turning into a
middle-aged man look at this right
here here's gravic and watch this guys
he looks directly at him the entire damn
time he 100 saw this transformation and
doesn't say now we get some boom booms
so we know how formidable an opponent
graphic is it's like an itty bitty Fano
snap
I'm sure the death of Agent Hill is
supposed to make me believe that no one
is safe but at this point I really don't
know how I can believe that Gamora came
back all the people that got blipped
came back heck Marvel denies it but for
a good time there even Phil Coulson was
back this slow pan up doesn't have me as
convinced as you think it does that this
isn't a scroll or that she's just in a
coma and not even dead yet do you want
ants because overcooking your steaks is
exactly how you get ants
foreign
what is real how do you define real then
where is Fury he's on favor
ites I need an extract fast
vanilla or strawberry
I think his face way off
Scrolls have infiltrated the ranks of
major world powers where is the truth
Yorkshire pudding I'm considered good
looking amongst my kindness It's a weird
flux but before Fury's in Township not
I'm sorry I I do not know this term 31
sir